so the brothers appeared in court seven
here at thames magistrate court both of
them pleading guilty to the charges they
faced so in the case of kurt zuma it was
the kicking of the cat in the abdomen
and slapping it in the head and in the
case of his younger brother johan zuma
it was aiding and abetting that offense
now this will relate to that video which
emerged at the beginning of february it
turns out that that video uh was
published published after
johan sent it to someone that he wanted
to go on a date with that night she was
appalled and that's how it then uh
became public and that video was filmed
by um you can hear him laughing there
are emojis over it and we heard in court
today from hazel stevens prosecuting for
the rspca who said that the cat had been
caused mental and physical unnecessary
suffering it had suffered pain fear and
anxiety after going through that
incident back in february and what she
also said is that once the video had
been enhanced the words had been
translated from french you could hear
kurt zuma saying it's starting are you
ready to get his brother ready to start
filming and he also says i swear i'll
kill it this is after the cat apparently
had broken vases uh which is why he felt
that he had to attack the cat well
clearly that hasn't gone down well he
has pleaded guilty they are due to come
back to this court on the first of june
to be sentenced